要不要想着是为孩子活，
我现在琢磨明白了，
姐妹们啊，
别想着是为孩子活，
我就为我自己活的，
为什么我看到孩子睡得香我高兴，
我看到孩子穿得漂亮我高兴，
我看到孩子健健康康的又长牙了，
我高兴都是为我高兴活着，
不要想着我是为孩子活着，
不想这个问题，
我的思路又升级了，
我就说我自己活，
我看到什么高兴，
这就是我活着的依托，
说跟我老公大家结婚了有5年，
然后岁了两个娃，
大女儿现在将近5岁，
小女儿的话一岁两个月就是我房子的话，
对我们登记之前他付的首付，
写的我们两个人的名字了，
婚后她是一直他在房贷款，
因为我们是买了那个精装房，
家具的家电之类的，
床啊用品，
所有的都是我在开支，
包括小孩子的吃的，
住着，
穿的这些所有东西就是我在负担，
我们之前一直是以这样的模式在活，
我生了二宝之后，
他对我的态度就是去沟通，
也不照顾小孩子的，
也不关心我，
这样我们的夫妻关系就比较稳断，
但情的你影响一就一直处于这种阶段，
如果说我想给他离的话，
我想要两个小孩子的抚养权，
我一那是在段生的，
房子一样的，
他结婚之前买的，
嗯，
付了首付，
都说他还的贷款就是已经还完了，
但是他最近两年的话呢，
他一直他信用卡，
今年9月份的话，
有一个朋友在银行里面工作，
现在。
借的，
他以我们夫妻的名义带了18万出来，
但是呢，
这个钱他没有一分都没给我，
我也不知道他这个钱是用到哪里去了，
我就是想说我养两个小孩子的抚养权也不是债务，
给他这个怎么能够挂一下，
他同意两个小孩都给你吗？
他肯定不同意的，
因为我跟他聊过这个事情，
他说两个小孩都跟他，
我说凭什么呢？
我说凭什么两个小孩都给你，
他说那行，
那女儿闺女啊，
那儿子给我，
他就想要那个儿子，
我也了解过，
一岁以内的小朋友去跟妈妈的嘛，
他没怎么照顾这两个小孩子，
他每天的工作习惯是什么呢？
就是睡到11点多钟，
晚上12点多钟一两点才回来，
他最近一天多的时间都是这样子的工作习惯，
早上吃完饭他就出去了，
从晚上就回来，
基本上没什么陪小孩子，
一天都没有过，
给小孩子什么东西都没买过，
比如说奶粉只要扣奶瓶，
衣服、
玩具啊几乎没买过，
用手指头都是数了出来，
是这样的啊，
就是说他如果不同意两个孩子都归你，
那你俩就得打官司，
打官司的话，
能不能这两个小孩都打到你名下来，
这个是有风险的，
未必能两个孩子都打到你的名下来，
我觉得与其这样的话，
还不如我就当你了，
是吧，
我就自己带着俩孩子过，
然后我跟你该签协议，
签协议，
各自的债务各自偿还，
哪些债务是归你的，
哪些债务是归我的，
哪些财产是归你的，
哪些财产是归我。
以后你每个月给我多少钱，
这样的话我可以带着两个孩子过，
不然的话，
如果要打官司的话，
你说两个孩子怎么都能打到你名下来，
谁能保证这两个孩子都打到你名下来，
谁也保证不了，
关键是他不会给钱的，
因为我上次我跟他讲了，
我说现在因为他爸爸帮我们带小孩嘛，
我把你儿子你女儿的生活费你也要出一点，
现在孩子也比较大，
他说那房贷、
房络费，
什么燃气费，
什么电费你也出一点，
我说那我去年在你公司上班一年的工资你给我结一下，
他说那你去诉讼吧，
我理解你啊，
就是现在我们陷入一种两难的困境啊，
如果是我的话，
我会怎么考虑这个问题啊，
反正爷爷奶奶现在免费的帮我带孩子呀，
带的是我的孩子呀，
我现在就要借助一切可以借助的力量，
爷爷奶奶帮我带孩子，
他顺便给我做饭呀，
我回来的时候有人洗衣服呀，
有人做饭呀，
我能够腾出大部分的时间，
我去挣钱去啊，
我只有挣到钱了，
如果有一天我能请得起保姆带着这俩孩子，
我给这俩孩子能提供好的吃的、
住的、
上学的环境了，
我才硬气，
我既然是有稳定收入了，
我自己能够养得起这两个小孩的，
我就不想跟他在这里内耗，
如果是这样的话，
你就带着两个小孩单过，
就把这两个小孩耗大一点，
比如说这两个小孩儿都跟你一起单过，
过了两三年了，
你再要求打官司要这两个小孩的抚养费也是有可能的，
毕竟还。
这个结婚我是异地，
不是外嫁的，
当时是没有要彩礼的，
就是在她的想法里面，
他是觉得好像她花了很多钱娶我，
她很亏的那种感觉，
但其实她真的什么都没出啊，
要么你就带着两个小孩儿回娘家过一段时间，
过了一年两年了之后，
再打了一通官司，
这俩小孩有可能归你，
因为俩小孩都已经跟你过习惯了，
你都照顾的挺好的，
你都有证据支撑你去把我去年11月份的有一个视频反复的看，
把那些证据都准备下来，
能证明你把孩子照顾的很好，
孩子跟着你也没有受什么苦，
然后证明他爸没有管过孩子，
也没有出过孩子的抚养费，
如果两三年之后是有可能这俩孩子都归你的，
就是我待回去去我娘家，
现在也不跟他离，
也不跟他那个啥是吧，
对，
因为你现在跟他离，
就算你打官司，
两个孩子是很难打给你一个人的，
很难的，
但是还有一种情况就是因为她现在债务比较多，
她有我不心里意据了18万，
反正你就要回娘家了是吧，
你回到娘家了之后，
你就换电话号码，
你名下就别存什么现金，
你名下就别有什么存款，
你还担心他欠债的事儿吗？
我怕他把两个小孩子带走之后，
我怕他断够，
我怕他付银行找我，
当时你欠字了，
是不是对你签字了，
这个事儿的话，
你只能寄希望于他能还得上。
他如果还不上的话，
到最后还是你的责任，
没事儿，
姐妹，
不管怎么样的话，
咱有两个健康的宝宝，
咱有希望，
咱有赚钱的能力，
咱们养活这两个健康的宝宝，
咱就很成功啊，
我在这里我过得一点都不开心，
而且又是异地，
没有人能跟你讲话，
虽然说是有在工作，
但不知道为什么活着这种感觉，
为了自己活呀，
我看到两个孩子的时候，
我是不是开心的，
看到孩子穿的高高兴兴的，
穿的漂漂亮亮的，
是不是开心呢？
为我自己活呀，
千万不要想着是为孩子活，
我现在琢磨明白了，
姐妹们啊，
别想着是为孩子活，
我就为我自己活的，
为什么我看到孩子睡得香我高兴，
我看到孩子穿得漂亮我高兴，
我看到孩子健健康康的又长牙了我高兴，
但是为我高兴活着不要想着，
我是为孩子活着，
不想这个问题，
我思路又升级了，
我就说我自己活，
我看到什么高兴，
这就是我活着的依托。
既然你建意我现在就跟她这样子，
如果说我接下来跟她继续这样子的话，
这两个小孩她依然不会管，
依然还是我一个人去管，
谁不是呢？
我直播间有多少姐妹，
孩子就你管的，
有的扣1，
谁不信呢？
大家都一样，
90%了，
就是我自己管，
我很开心啊。
如果说看到我和他爸一起过去的话，
孩子会绕过他爸来，
跑过来抱我，
谁不信呢？
有没有自己会想问题啊，
我会想问题啊，
我一切都是会。
我自己，
我自己干什么高兴，
我看到孩子穿新衣服我高兴我买，
我看到孩子吃什么排骨，
我高兴，
我买，
我看到孩子天天的就是玩什么游戏开心，
我给他买，
我看到孩子去什么游乐场开心，
我带他去，
一切都是为我高兴，
不要想着我是为孩子，
我从此之后再也不说我是为孩子活着的，
我就是为我自己活着的，
这干这事我高兴，
我愿意干，
不用牵扯别人，
别牵扯，
就这意思，
就是像我在朋友圈这一块，
我现在我肯定是不一定能跟得到是吧，
现在这个状态很难还有这个债务，
反正也是割不开是吧，
你自己签了字的，
你怎么能割得开呢？
签了字的肯定是割不开的呀，
我就觉得人都不能扯到这种地，
现在挺好的啊，
姐妹，
我没有别的意思啊，
我呢，
昨天又看到一个视频，
3岁的一个小姑娘，
这个3岁的小姑娘就是在监控底下啊，
在一个小马桶上，
她自己会脱裤子了，
自己上了一个小马桶，
然后他爸爸走出来了之后就抱着姑娘就在那里痛哭流涕，
原因是什么？
因为这3岁的小姑娘是一个孤独症患者，
他是不知道爸爸妈妈的，
你跟他讲什么他也不能理解的，
所以到3岁了，
他第一次会自己去小马桶上坐着坐着尿尿啊什么的，
他爸爸都激动的都哭了，
抱着孩子就亲啊什么的，
我一看那个评论区，
全都是在那里说我的孩子7岁了，
以前我跟他。
讲话他都没有回复，
终于有一天我问他，
你笑啥呢？
这孩子回了一句我开心啊，
那一瞬间妈妈就愣在那里了，
然后眼睛就不自觉的流下了眼泪，
因为他以前跟孩子讲什么，
孩子都是不回应了，
突然一天孩子说了一句我开心啊，
就是妈妈就受不了了。
我想讲这个没有别的意思，
没有这个比惨的意思，
我就是想要告诉你，
有两个健康的宝宝，
他们的存在可以让你开心，
他们的存在可以让你快乐。
对这件事情本身他是福气来的，
他不是理所当然我们每个人都可以拥有的东西，
你明白了吗？
供你参考啊。
但是我还想再问一个问题，
如果说等这两个小孩到了8岁以后，
我再去跟他问这两个有没有可能之类的，
有可能不会听从你小朋友的意见，
是吗？
哎呀，
我现在我跟他的关系就是住在一个房子里面，
可能我没有你想的那么开放，
看过你那个视频，
你说就当他这个工具，
就当他啊，
就当他不存在，
但是其实做到这个自己呢，
会觉得自己在这个地方很压抑，
你可以自己回一趟娘家呀，
别见场给自己放个假，
谢谢，
嗯，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
我跟你讲，
我在直播间我说的很多话都是我自己，
现实生活中我就是这么干的，
内心真实的想法就是这样的，
每一次我看到我的孩子的时候，
我要时刻的提醒我自己就是孩子，
那么健康，
长得那。
好，
他是福报，
他不是我理所当然就拥有的一切。
我，
我跟你们讲过，
我的孩子在3个月的时候呛过一次奶，
差点我就好像要失去他了。
那一刻开始，
我每一次跟孩子在一起的时候，
我都会告诉我自己，
孩子平安健康是我的福报，
不是我理所当然就能拥有的东西。
我希望这个点能让所有的想要对孩子发脾气的妈妈，
就像廖智说那句话，
每一次你想要对孩子发脾气的时候，
请你允许你的爱意先抵达到孩子的身边，
就是孩子，
他能平安健康，
他有一颗善良的心，
他有的时候可以看到妈妈的辛苦。
就这一点的话，
他是福报，
他不是你理所当然每天都可以拥有的东西。
记得点赞关注哦。